Thanks thanks for being here everyone
I'm Ryan as Eric said this is
accelerating single-cell bioinformatics
with n dimensional arrays in the cloud
which is a lot but we're gonna get
through it in three parts single cell
sequencing is an exciting new
measurement technology with profound
implications for a lot of biology and
medicine it generates array data that we
want to store and process and this being
2019 we often want to do that in public
clouds or various cluster contexts and
that presents interesting challenges so
I work at nan Sinai in New York at a
laser 'sons lab and this work was funded
by the Chan Zuckerberg initiative and as
part of the human cell Atlas which is a
big consortium essentially dedicated to
standardizing around these single cell
analyses how we perform them what the
data should look like what the tools
that process that data should look like
etc and my colleague Tom white in
particular did most of the work I'm
going to talk about today lots of
there's a slides bitly that's at the
bottom of this slides maybe hard to see
it's bitly PI data are W lots of things
here are linked if you want to follow up
there so agenda basically I'll talk
about what why single cell sequencing is
interesting and exciting essentially it
allows us to go from bulk sequencing of
cells to resolving the RNA of individual
cells which allows us to just know many
more things than conventional genome
sequencing has allowed storing the data
today and most of the tools that operate
on this data use hdf5 as an archival
storage format and there are some rough
edges to using it and we've been
somewhat evangelizing a upstart
container storage technology called czar
that's very similar but plays more
nicely with
parallel compute paradigms and cloud
storage so I will talk about the two of
those and other relevant technologies in
the space and I'll talk about work we've
done to allow existing tools that
already process this data to be run
seamlessly in parallel using a variety
of parallelization backends that we're
living through a small Renaissance and
there are many interesting choices that
you may like to try out
so a quick somewhat silly exercise is
we'll just contextualize some of the
basic biology that's relevant to
understanding why single-cell sequencing
is interesting the biological
information essentially progresses from
DNA to RNA to proteins which is
analogous to information on your
computer being stored or Chi Valley on a
hard disk it's very large in size you're
typically not using most of what you're
storing at any given point the bits that
you do want to use you page into memory
which is like RNA it's more volatile and
ephemeral much smaller in size though
the information is still very
identifiably the same as it was on disk
just in a different physical substrate
and eventually all of the work actually
happens by proteins interacting and
essentially performing computations by
their 3d confirmations binding to one
another or not and that's kind of like
how the information gets chopped and
massaged in various ways and ends up in
the CPU registers and actually goes out
and affects the world maybe include
network cards and other interfaces with
the world in this in that last portion
an interesting question is if you want
to understand a population of cells or a
computer system which of these stages
would you like to be able to read the
information at they each tell you
different things that could be more or
less useful depending on the questions
you want to ask and we've still to date
we we have very little very limited
ability to read proteins should be
analogous like sampling live CPU read
SURS off of a running machine we have
pretty well developed abilities to read
from disk and memory DNA and RNA though
with some important caveats that single
cell sequencing helps to remove which is
why it's interesting so just another
take on this metaphor is that DNA is
like the apps you have installed on your
computer there could be many of them
they're mostly not running at any given
point the apps are like genes different
machines with the same apps installed
could be running different apps and
present to the world very differently
they could use the same disk image you
could be operating as a web server or
graphic design workstation or an email
video chat client or a development
workstation and those actual programs do
send Network requests and create audio
and visual signals that actually
interact with the world and that's like
proteins so the important breakthrough
here is to move from bulk sequencing to
single cell sequencing all the genome
sequencing that you've ever heard of for
10 or 20 years has been bulk sequencing
we take a population of cells and we
sample from the DNA and RNA across that
population but without any ability to
resolve that to which specific cells
those samples came from it just can be
very useful for a lot of things we've
learned a lot from DNA both sequencing
technologies as they've existed to date
but there are important questions that
it doesn't help us answer or what like
when we really want to get into
populations of cells where we know there
are subgroups that are functioning as
web servers or graphic design
workstations and they're interacting
with each other in different ways and
just finding out that half of the cells
are running Chrome or a terminal doesn't
really tell us that finer structure that
is important to get a deeper
understanding of what types of cells
there are and how they're interacting
so the ability to now sequence and
resolve at single cell level instead of
these bulk samples is essentially thanks
to a clever chemistry trick that where
we pre process the cells before putting
them through the same bulk sequencing
pipelines which is great because we can
reuse the existing billions of dollars
of investment in genome sequencing
machines we still put them through these
books sequencing pipelines but we
barcode them first we have this like
pre-processing step where the cells go
through this very narrow tube that only
one cell fits through at a time and they
get pinched into oil droplets with beads
that are covered in barcodes and a given
bead has many copies of just one barcode
that's essentially a physical UUID
it's like a short sequence of RNA base
pairs that is globally unique you know
it's just enough of them there's a CG or
T so it's 4 raised to the power of the
length of the RNA sequence without going
very long you have a sequence that's
unlikely to have existed anywhere in the
world before and you put the cells in
individual droplets with these beads
that are covered in barcodes and the
beads degrade the cell and the barcodes
hybridize to the ends of all of the RNA
molecules in the cell and now you can
pool all the cells that are post bar
coding back together and push them
through the bulk sequencing pipeline but
all the samples that you're getting of
RNA molecules from cells have this
barcode on the end of it that you know
came from one of these beads that was
only in a droplet with one specific cell
so if you group them in software
according to their barcodes you know
that any reads with the same barcode all
came from the same cell if they have
different barcodes they were from
different cells so it essentially lets
us join the reads better resolve the
reads back to the individual cells that
they came from
not sure how clear that is but it's not
super important because after that we
crossed the Rubicon from wet lab to dry
lab and we get all of our problems
become software problems where we get
what's called an expression matrix which
is essentially a giant sparse matrix of
cells by genes that just says how many
samples from each cell we got that were
showed that it was expressing each gene
and most of the entries are 0 most cells
are not expressing most genes or they
are in very like vanishingly small
quantities so we don't end up sampling
from it and then we just have these
matrices that we want to do various
things like identify common patterns of
genes that are being expressed in
different cells essentially cluster them
together to identify cell types that
exist in a way that's better than
anything we were able to do previously
so this is an animation of like the
beads going through one of these droplet
pinching pipelines and then coming from
down on top you'd in in the real thing
there would be like a cell which would
get pinched into one of these droplets
along with the bead and most of the
droplets end up empty so many of the
beads will go through and not have a
cell in them and cells might miss beads
but the important thing is if it's if
both channels in are dilute enough you
only end up with maximum one bead and
one cell in a given droplet and you
filter out for those and you just work
with those downstream so the human cell
Atlas is this multi year multi Institute
initiative to standardize around the
data that comes off of these experiments
how we run the experiments in the first
place so that we can pool these datasets
and generally do good science around
this like exciting new kind of data that
we can get access to the ability to push
cells through these pipelines has been
exponentially increasing which you can
see on this chart
the largest public data set is about a
million cells and we expect even larger
than that to come out whenever it's kind
of a big race among people that run
these sequencing pipelines to try and do
more and push more and more cells
through these pipelines also even given
existing datasets that were done in
separate experiments like if they're
both human cells they have the same
genes that are being measured so you can
in principle just concatenate the
matrices and have a bigger data set with
more cells that you can run a holistic
analysis over assuming that we've
accounted for lots of biases that would
otherwise creep in unless we were being
organized and how different people run
these experiments and stuff so humans
sellout it's basically like the Human
Genome Project but 20 years later in
response to a new different sequencing
breakthrough ok
so analyzing this data as I said there's
we we have these sparse matrices that
are cells by genes if it's human cells
and it's the same 30,000 or so genes
every time and the largest data said I
mentioned was 1.3 million cells so
that's like 40 billion elements in the
matrix and it's most of them are 0 it's
maybe like a billion nonzero elements
it's still it's it's of a size that you
can just deal with on your laptop kind
of today but it's a bit unwieldy and
there's an emergent need to be able to
use bigger and multiple machines to deal
with this data and especially if the
datasets get larger that will be a more
pressing need the kinds of analyses we
do to this data are basically in two
camps there's like pre-processing stuff
where we just want to like we happen to
get more samples from one cell versus
another and we want to normalize that
out and just treat each cell like we got
a distribution of what genes it's
expressing and then various flavors of
clustering we want to identify motifs of
gene expression that
are essentially types of cells that we
then can understand what they do or how
they interact with the other types
better and stuff so there's several
pretty mature tools for dealing with
this data that largely come out of
institutions where they are generating
the sequencing data and the scientists
themselves have built these tools that
very effectively answer the questions
that they have about the data scan pi is
the most popular one in python there's a
few in the our world they all have
pretty healthy open source ecosystems
and they all persist their data using
hdf5 in one fashion or another which
I'll talk about in a second
so things that my group has wanted to
help these tools do better is to process
the data out of core deal with datasets
that are larger than fit in memory often
like leave the data sets remote
somewhere not have to download it it's
your laptop or your workstation to deal
with it and also operate it operate on
it in parallel and it's hard to do these
with hdf5 which has been the de facto
standard format that these tools are
using so we kind of backed into having
to think about how we store is array
data for in this domain and it has
implications for other domains as well
hdf5 is a very esteemed standard way
that a lot of scientific domains have
stored datasets for decades you can
store heterogeneous data and the
metadata associated with it in single
large files on anything that looks like
a file system essentially and transfer
those large files atomically the
metadata stays co-located with the data
that it describes has a lot of good
properties like that it basically works
by embedding a virtual file system
inside of this single large file on your
file system like kind of like a zip
archive or
things not vain you have this like
nested directory structure where the
directories are actually called groups
and your files inside those groups that
are data sets which are
multi-dimensional arrays fixed types and
whatever metadata you have that's
associated with them
you can randomly access inside of these
arrays and slice them in different ways
and it supports pluggable compression an
interesting distinction is that it's not
really a file format but more like a
meta format meta file format like if you
want to store data in HDFS ID on a
directory structure and names of the
groups and the datasets and the shapes
and the types that they will be inside
your hd5 so that's somebody else's
software that looks at one of your hdf5
files knows what to expect and can read
them it's kind of a now I guess to
choosing a database to use but and you
still need to decide what tables you
want to exist and what schemas those
tables will have if you want other
people to interact with your database so
it's kind of at that higher level of
abstraction than a specific file format
every different scientific domain has
its own conventions around what files
directories and files they put inside
their hdf5 files and that's second level
if they standardize around so we found
some we found it difficult to do what we
want with hdf5 in a few ways it's it's
kind of it's been around a long time it
has a lot it's grown organically to an
extreme degree there's a very
complicated spec there's a lot of
functionality that most people don't use
but that's in there and there's only one
bonafide implementation that I'm aware
of of that spec which is the official C
library that's maintained by the hdf5
group and there's bindings for almost
every language to work with hdf5 files
but they all essentially call this one C
library that's a bit opaque perhaps just
as an outsider but it's a bit daunting
to try to make changes to it it's not
it's not an obvious public issue tracker
and things like this doesn't present as
a regular open source project that I'm
used to dealing with
in particular it doesn't that the sea
library that everything uses only it
uses system calls to access local files
only there's no way to point it at cloud
stores using like Python and Java at
least have pretty well established
interfaces for just swapping in Google
Cloud storage or s3 or what have you
inside some kind of interface that
presents like a regular file system and
lets you work with files that are either
local or remote in these cloud stores
there's no real way to inject that into
this sea library like if you're using
the Python bindings you're kind of stuck
and it also just by the the design where
you have these single large files it
doesn't play very nicely with parallel
reading and writing in general it's very
hard if you have a thousand workers and
you're trying to write one giant file
and have them each write one one
thousandth of it number one it's hard to
do in software you have to know exactly
how you know what the byte ranges are
gonna be ahead of time for each of these
like random offsets which is difficult
if you're gonna compress the data and
also most file system like things won't
actually give you a thousand way
parallelism when you're doing that it's
like one disk head that's trying to it's
getting dass attacked by your thousand
workers essentially so so that doesn't
work well and kind of can't be made to
work well as long as these things are
supposed to be just one big file and
then parallel reading it could work in
principle you can split these files and
drop workers in at random offsets to
read just disjoint shards of the data
but the general ecosystem for doing both
of these is just not very well developed
and because it just hasn't been a
priority for this project that's you
know these are kind of more recent
concerns I guess and this project has
been around a long time before we cared
as much about that I think so in the
single cell and a few other domains
people were interested in finding
something simpler and friendlier to
remote storage and parallel processing
so Zahra is an interesting project that
has a reference Python implementation
and vibrant open-source community around
that it basically does the same thing
you have these like directories and
a dimensional array data sets that can
be stored in nested directory structures
the arrays are chunked and each chunk is
its own file on an underlying filesystem
which plays nicely with the ways that
parallel processing is typically done in
the Hadoop ecosystem and elsewhere so an
example simple like two dimensional
array is here on the top right where
this would be like the contents of one
directory on your file system that has
four of these chunk files that are each
is like two dimensions and two chunks
along each axis so 0 0 0 1 etc and a
metadata files the array that's just a
JSON blob that tells you the size of the
whole array the size of the chunks the
data type being stored which is like
signed integers and a pluggable
compression algorithm and the chunk
files themselves are just this 10 by 10
chunks of integers in row major order so
just 100 for byte integers run through Z
Lib and that's the file you have on disk
so it's much more approachable using
official czar libraries and not spec is
very simple it has it doesn't have a lot
of stuff bolted on to it yet it's new
it's we get to bolt stuff on and make it
harder to reason about over the years
but for now it does vary a few things
very well which is nice and there's been
a few implementations in other languages
already so the community around it is
growing and being somewhat officially
adopted by the human cell Atlas for
storing and processing this data it
played it also plays nicely with
existing language bindings for talking
to public clouds for example I can
Python the mutable mapping
implementations of Google and Amazon
just work on forzar data that you access
through the pythons our library
something else relevant in this space of
container formats is the common data
model and its implementations called
netcdf which is an older project that
essentially standardized around hdf5 and
several other similar projects that all
do a similar
thing where they have these
multi-dimensional arrays and some nested
directory structure they all have this
in common plus or minus some other
auxilary features and so it represents
that core that they all support and and
it has at least a java implementation
that's from scratch of the bits of hdf5
that conform to this common data model
so most likely what's gonna happen is R
will be one of the supported backends
for for this common data model and can
just exist in that community of things
that are relatively portable from one to
the next and across scientific domains
which is nice so things that we've
actually done to date we've put ZAR
support into scan pi so that instead of
just using HT fi files you can store and
read and write data sets using as our
single cell sequencing data sets so they
work in against cloud backends
it's definitely low-hanging
optimizations to do but I think the
model basically works we want to do
similar things to the our tools but
haven't got around to it yet and it's a
little harder to see how to insert this
abstraction in those in that ecosystem
we've done some work to improve the
tooling around hdf5 itself as part of
just doing technical diligence to see if
we can make HD fi of work so we don't
have to try to push a different format
on people we use this the netcdf Java
implementation of hdf5 and swapped the
Java n io file system interface in for
in to its IO layer so that it can use
existing Java and IO implementations of
Google Cloud or s3 file systems so that
we can read and write hdf5 files
directly in these cloud stores which to
my own knowledge is the only language
where that exists and we even put spark
bindings over the read path of that so
we can drop kind of like I described
earlier we can drop spark workers in it
random offsets in these arrays even
remotely in the cloud even though it's
hdf5 data and have them basically look
like a hadoop input format that a lot of
workers can read from in parallel so
some things you can make work there but
some other things are
what answer insurmountable Tom built
this library called zappy that
essentially you presents an interface
like numpy arrays but has pluggable
distributed backends so you can use
spark or Beam or pi Ren which
essentially forms your array chunk
computations out to AWS lambdas which is
a really cool model that I'm excited
about and that's live in scan pi so you
can process single-cell data using any
of these backends and we ran some
scaling benchmarks and it does about
what you it expects like you can throw
more cores at it and have the runtime go
down basically linearly but subject to
some upfront fixed cost of using these
like heavier weight distributed tools
which is usually how that works
desk is the original version of that
trick where it's just like look it's
like an umpire array but it will sent
it'll just repeat your computations on
those arrays for you over a coupie
Nettie's cluster so we also support that
as a back-end in scan pi and that works
well and yeah so things were planning to
do to extend this is to benchmark on
larger data sets for now we think we'll
just take the existing public data sets
and concatenate them to themselves a
bunch of times to get synthetic larger
data sets but perhaps real sequencing
pipelines will scale to these numbers
soon and we want to push this like
parallel and cloud friendly computation
further in the single-cell pipelines
today it's just doing these like
pre-processing steps that are a bit
simpler more just like map stages and
less reduce and shuffle and so things
like clustering and indexing and
searching are much more interesting
algorithms to also lift into this
distributed paradigm and we want to
expand all this to the our ecosystem
tools that are relevant here and so yeah
that's where we are today we've got
we're you know we're approaching this
data that is processed today by a few
different tools written a few different
languages and we want them to be remote
storage and parallel processing friendly
across a few different parallelization
engines we have the initial scaling and
distribution work is going about as well
as we'd expect and there's this library
zappy which gives you arrays with
pluggable distributed backends which can
be potentially relevant across a lot of
different kinds of problems so that's
all I have
I'll take questions now we have time
[Applause]
what's the size of your data sets
typically you know for like a hundred
thousand or whatever sells you know
what's the size yeah the most of the
data sets people are dealing with these
days are smaller let's say like ten
thousand cells and those would be
anywhere from tens to hundreds of
megabytes and so it's really no problem
to deal with them on a single node the
largest data set is like 1.3 million
cells and that's a couple of gigabytes I
think like compressed and so when you
actually uncompress it and iterate over
it it can be more unwieldy like people
to try to run these existing tools on
that data set people will use even
hundreds of gigabytes of memory and
that's it hasn't really been optimized
it's kind of like no one's fully tackled
that problem yet a lot of times they'll
just like filter out a bunch of the data
before they try to process it according
to some hard cutoff is one way to avoid
that problem I don't know if that okay
and so you said you optimized using
spark on on storing the data and at this
other excuse me at the same time you're
using Tzar but you things are could be
more intensive so which do you feel is
better spark on SD f5 or czar on it's
done yeah so we can we can use spark in
a limited capacity for data for hd5 data
it's very easy to use spark on czar data
and it works much better like out of the
box essentially
if you point it at these czar
directories where the chunks are already
logical files like that's usually how
spark expects data to come in it's like
a directory that's a data set and it's
been chunked into per chunk files inside
that directory so it looks just like
that and it works almost for free and
spark so
that make sense
I thank you so much that was really
interesting kind of the biologist
medical person question it seems like
there are a lot of potential
applications with like cancer tumors and
that sort of sequencing has is this
being used more and more within medical
research yeah absolutely cancer is a big
focus for this kind of data particularly
because like genome sequencing when
you're if you're just getting the same
information from all the cells that
works in like if all of your cells have
the same germline DNA but in a cancer
setting all you want to know what's
different from cell to cell actually and
that is important information there are
many companies that are aggressively
pursuing drugs that work based on these
principles and lots of it's a super
active area of research and production
ization
I'm not as plugged into that but yeah
the answer is yes got time for one more
so you mentioned zappy what like what
are some differences between that and
like desc
you're talking about - beta frames and
yeah they're very similar desk has its
own model for farming out the
computations to workers that you
register with it or that it is
maintaining for you as you know it's
like running a kubernetes cluster that
on your behalf and spark and beam and PI
R n the other other backends are
supported by zappy are just different
implementations of that same idea that
have their own bells and whistles that
may be better or worse but it's kind of
there's an emergent need I think to
abstract over these different ways to
parallel to do this this trick where
it's like you want to pretend you just
have this array it's being paralyzed
somehow there's different there's a lot
of choices that go into how that
paralyzation is implemented and what
kinds of resources it's implemented on
top of etc etc those tools are already
many tools are mature and have huge
ecosystems that do that and so we want
to if you for some reason know that
you're using some part of this that
works better on SPARC you can send it to
spark back in or if it works better on
task or you're more comfortable with
these kubernetes clusters that it is
based on you can use tasks for that yeah
all right well thank Ryan again thank
you